hello everybody and welcome to you
guessed it the top five best top five
episodes oh my god right super meta over
here absolutely you guys have been
asking for that for a long time I've
seen a lot of comments on Twitter
Facebook I'm YouTube comments here
like what is the best top five episodes
well these are some of our favorites
that we're gonna tell you about right
now I know everyone has their own
favorites none of these are wrong none
of yours are wrong okay this is a
subjective thing literally a hundred to
choose from so you know right that's why
we're doing this because we got through
a hundred episodes of top five this is
episode 101 okay that's a milestone
amazing oh we got two three digits man
that's pretty crazy that Rob is dead I
love it no more die no Rob and we get to
talk about and reflect on our work a
little bit so let's get into number five
right now Heather it's something that I
think you have a passing familiarity
with yes our number five item on the
list here is one of the first top fives
that I ever hosted so it's a very
memorable one for me and probably one of
my personal favorites as well so here it
is number five number five
top five worst Walter Benassi act
performances so this actually kind of
started as a discussion months before
this week talking about funny April
Fool's top fives and we came up with the
idea of what what would happen if we did
a top five worst Walter performances
right this was the result obviously we
thought it was funny enough to go ahead
with it right it's not a usual episode
of the top five it's but never back down
because I was still doing actors and
actors at that point just look at some
of my older stuff some very old stuff
right and just kind of poked some fun at
myself and everything and that was a fun
thing to do and having Heather hosted
she did a great job it's an interesting
challenge writing for someone making fun
of me right let's you know the things
though I feel like sometimes if I'm just
writing to like make fun of you I I
might hit a cut that's just too deep so
at least I didn't cut too no you could
have said whatever at this point I mean
like the job back then obviously was
just doing best and worst at
performances from actors and stuff so
it's only fair that I get the worst you
know part - right I mean that's fine I
mean every week I see it in comments
anyway I'm terrible I'm awful so now you
got to see me at my worst the actual
actual worst one was an actual high
school project yes oh my gosh and that
was the super caper kick safety shuttle
Michaels I know nothing about wrestling
so I'm reading this script that Walter
sent me and I'm like panel I have to
talk like Shawn Michaels and then do
those super cute super kick good one I
don't look it up good something like
five things to be able to be like oh
yeah I uploaded all those on my personal
channel to go on there and make fun of
me all you want right I mean we can't
talk about them and not let the people
be able to judge for themselves yes no
war I'm still here my first two feature
films I did with my best friends and
super take safety are all in my personal
channel so you can revel in my
embarrassment as well I think the
opening bit a lot of people still talk
about
yes that's good it all works out pretty
well it was definitely one of my
favorites I don't know if this is
conceded putting my own top five five
list but I'm gonna put in there anyway
men because it was fine yeah it was one
of my favorite sherry and I know like
the day premiered people were still like
wow it's been three days since April
Fool's but I mean thought it was funny
it was right after April Fool's I mean
that's just one top five came out on the
Tuesday right
a brains was a couple days before us
right what do you want from me man I
can't get everything exactly perfect
right but that was a lot of fun man I
think that uh yeah this is one of my
favorites for sure I'm glad you got to
host it what we're gonna be doing in
between the numbers here I'm gonna
introduce something some of our favorite
moments from the show as well so I want
to throw to our favorite gags our
favorite little skits and intros I'm
gonna cut to that right now so go ahead
and take it away
[Music]
hey we see the worst of Nicolas Cage
let's do this
[Music]
there's hands toes toes toes yeah yeah
Optimus Primal maximize
[Music]
number four top five best / worst of the
room moments this was a really fun one I
am I got to cause this one with me this
is a funny story behind this one I
thought I'd still call in and give my
thoughts on the best / worst moments
from the room I liked when Walter and I
actually went to a screening of the room
before seeing the disaster artists and
yes we were actually pelted by raining
plastic spoons I also really liked
making the room opening when I got to
walk Walter through each of the scenes
from the movie I was super fun and we
even got to have a catch
oh yeah and best of all I got to pit
that Dobie Dobie this was a surprisingly
difficult countdown to decide since the
whole movie is the disaster that you
can't look away from but how do you
choose the best or I guess the worst
it's tearing me apart Walter yeah I
never saw the room before this this
episode of that bud and disasters was
coming I was the perfect storm of
terribleness at this point and you know
my favorite episode of nostalgia critic
is the room mine too
yeah yeah and I think everyone voted
when we did the top five best historical
episodes they voted for that as if they
were as well so everyone really likes
the episode it was a eventful time for
me and I think the episode captured a
lot of that stuff you know the room is
kind of an easy target I think we could
say but at the same time I thought we
did a lot of really flying bits in there
and Ayana was thank you very much Ayanna
where every people are we've had a lot
of great guests on top five
oh they're included of you even before
your normal host on the show Ayanna
Tamra
hello Greedo a lot of people who have
closed to the show with me over these
couple years and we're gonna get to some
of the favorite moments that we have of
those guests right now so take it away
get you to think of something
ah no the skeletons behind you they do
really good work yes you dumb get to
work what's up with the power ranger
helmet oh I just wanted to make you feel
at home it's okay you don't have to wear
that I think I did alter take off the
helmet okay you're doing a top five of
DBZ and you didn't invite me
let's do this football head hey I am NOT
doing my Stanley impression all right
it's not gonna happen
big day who dares summon her great I
shaved my head for nothing we'll catch
you on the next page
awesome comics isn't coming back number
three top 5 best nostalgia critic
episodes so this is I'm pretty sure the
longest episode of top five this is
almost 30 minutes yeah I really put a
lot of work into this
yeah well that's part of what's great
about the episode is that you can tell
that it wasn't just okay another episode
like I loved that we had your input
everyone was all got to vote obviously
it was a lot of a labor of love from you
know something that you were like yeah
this is awesome I'm excited to do this
right I mean I had that idea like a
month before and I think I called Doug
to ask if that would be cool to like
celebrate the 10 year anniversary of
masada Creek and everything and I I was
I've told this story before but I am a
nostalgia critic fan before you know
joining Chen Lawson or anything I did
watch Doug four years beforehand so yeah
like we said the room got number one
there you know the it review the
original movie and there a lot of
classic right baman baman
yeah right I mean bad credit card can't
really top that in that moment I think
is maybe the top nostalgia critic moment
what he remembers the most people still
go up to Doug and asked him about that
stuff great so I'm glad that Doug let me
do that and it was it was really kind of
a labor of love for me to go through all
that stuff and I really liked the intro
I'm really proud of how that intro
turned out kind of starting at his first
review and doing like the rewind thing
and everything so that worked out really
well I thought the interviews were
really insightful and everyone I thought
everyone involved did a great job just
talking about the legacy of the show and
the stuff that they were involved in so
it was a lot of fun to put together I'm
really really proud of that one it's
also the top viewed episode of top five
okay we were trending actually I forgot
about your trailer for a little bit
there that's pretty cool is it's a
pretty cool achievement and I'm really
proud of that episode and if you guys
are watching this channel you feel the
same way that I do about nostalgic who
can we think so thanks for watching him
for ten years thanks for watching this
show for over 100 episodes now and there
are still two more episodes to get to
there are yes so before we get to number
two I did want to mention that there's a
there's a guy on the show I'm a big fan
of a certain man he kind of comes in the
background a lot of the time mr. Jim Jay
Roz I'm also a big fan of we all are
made a few words on this show but what
the things that make me laugh the most
on top five are always it's always chill
whatever no matter how many times I've
seen you if I'm watching back editing or
just an I haven't seen an episode of a
long time and one of his moments comes
up I always just laugh it's so great so
we're here's a little compilation of my
favorite Jim moments right now you want
to do the countdown with me know
oh hi Jim you're pathetic
hey Jim can you build me a suit of armor
from scratch sure thing hey Jim can you
build a spaceship by tomorrow no problem
hey Jim can you harness the power of
darkness through music you got it just
stay out of my goddamn steel shop
whatever I'm supposed to be some kind of
Disney princess and I'm a vampire
how in government there now I feel
stupid
[Music]
number two top five best 90s Nickelodeon
shows got a special guest for this who
was on the episode I thought you did a
great job getting chilly counts of our
favorite 90s Nickelodeon memories
fighting Rob on it
this is a rare non Dino Rob right
appearance these kiddies kid Rob dad
right like those those shirts are so
awesome we got that at c2e2 the
convention in Chicago which is perfect
cuz Robin we I mean it was perfect for
the episode but we really do talk about
80 sources yes a lot all the time and I
addressed somewhere in the middle which
yeah so playing that up for the episode
I thought it was really cool just you
know I just want him to wear the shirt
first but then he came in was like whoa
I'm gonna put on this red mohawk and
like he's loving the shame I was like I
didn't ask you to do we are in it's
genius yeah thank you it is hilarious I
rewatched it very recently this pillar
that intro is very funny with them you
turned the Clarissa explains it all
thing into my Tamara's never seen in
yeah a lot of mileage out of that that
was a lot of fun to put together this is
why I like this episode so much because
we did like these little intros and
outros that had to do with the shows
that we were talking about and I
definitely my favorite one was the
Clarissa intro you got to do so I got to
do the snap and then go in to spell out
your name and everything it's perfect
for the Tamra's never seen intro but I
have to admit something I think I just
love getting to watch at least one or
two episodes of all that stuff yeah and
then talking about are you afraid of
dark I love our intro than are afraid of
the dark with the you know the lights
off and let me see you lash lights and
everything yeah and that you know birth
the the October top 5 that year we did
are you afraid of the dark and goose
bumps
so what you guys really really like so
um we got a lot of stuff out of this
episode and I love 90s Nickelodeon you
know I did the Nicktoons before that and
doing the live-action shows with you on
board that was great I'm glad you got to
be on there it was really fun yeah also
with the the Hey Arnold episodes yeah
and you're on there with they are onto
like you're my Nickelodeon buddy the
second best of all yes I love it I was
being you did it so you know I'm today
as recording this is National Power
Rangers day I'm wearing my Power Rangers
colors a big part of this show
throughout like little blips of power
and your stuff in there and my main
enemy we just talked about him Dino rabe
to the death we fought he died I want
that up I did nighttime if we didn't see
it maybe you should go over the back the
last episode and watch that I killed him
we actually killed him so he's dead now
and all's right with the world but we
had a lot of good times while he was
here so here are some of our favorite
moments with Power Rangers and battle
[Music]
and the number one best top-five episode
in the top five worst Full House
episodes so this one had a lot of people
in it just about everybody at some point
including Ankara Quinn my real actual
right we were talking about the idea of
this episode and I was just kind of like
well you know I have a real twin sister
if you want us to like do the Michelle
thing and we'll do the Olsen twins
ignite which out in it well we switch in
and out and like we'll both be in the
intro and that was so much fun that it
was great man
it was great and just you know like Mark
III went like through that intro a full
house like really meticulously yeah and
tried like every little zoom out or zoom
in like I copied for our our intro
alright I thought that intro turned out
so good we got to have a drone shot um
so my my cousin Alyssa I got to shoot
some stuff really for us that was bad
look really good
we got the intro with the cityscape and
everything which looked great which
added some some depth to this a little
intro for us Barney made the music for
us yeah so yeah I just this was a real
team effort one for that intro I thought
it just turned out so well I
legitimately do love fallout yes so I
got an act really don't hate hate so
much nostalgia quick review of that from
all the stars
but yeah so like I just wrote a thing
with I was annoying everyone with how
much I love full house and they got sick
of it so they kind of down the worst
full-house episodes and you know took me
out of the equation so as a writer for
this this is probably favorite episode
that I wrote because I got to write for
everyone else mocking a show that I love
but in everyone else's voices especially
in Doug's voice because you know like I
just really tried to make my best
attempt at a a nostalgia critic rant
right in there I think it off really
well yeah I mean obviously it's all in
the performance and you know I've
watched so many nostalgia critic
episodes I think I know his voice decent
right and what he would say in certain
situations so I thought that it turned
out really well with him reading off
that stuff and even everyone else like
Malcolm stuff was really funny I thought
your stuff and your sister stuff hey I'm
you switching guys switching out in
between cuts and then kind of noticing
it yes and there was a cut that you
didn't end up using because there's one
take there's one take where Doug
actually turned to her and was like
which didn't end up in the final episode
I wanted to keep a little eyes through
there but that's right and you look in
the background like eventually they
start noticing that you're not identical
like at least I don't think we look
alike so I didn't think the joke would
be like I do like the funny but like
yeah I love the comments where people
were like in in the comments where they
were saying and if I creep and some are
in the background like something wrong
Heather forget the fool a couple people
so yeah that was great
so yeah just as a writing challenge this
was great as a putting you know wearing
for other people and just trying to
capture voices and doing that intro this
all worked out like perfectly I think
and I love full house still but it was
great to sort of tap into what people
don't like about the show and just sort
of dig into that and like let other
people talk about it for me so I know
full house not perfect okay we get it
yeah I mean I know a lot of people know
well and actually one of my favorite I
was just thinking about this one of my
favorite gifts like ever of channel
awesome came out of this episode as well
when we're talking about the fundraising
episode and it's I thought like my
favorite yeah I just wanted to say thank
you very much for watching a hundred
episodes of top 5 so far please keep
watching we have a lot of great stuff in
the pipeline coming up here for the rest
of the year yeah and having Ayana back
on board when she's coming back right
will be great to have the trio back
together again next week so thank you
guys for watching uh Heather where can
we check out on social media well you
can find me on Twitter Instagram or
Twitter I play games on Wednesday nights
yeah you can check me out on Twitter
which is at awesome underscore Walter or
you can go on Facebook where I'm on a
little bit more often these days which
is facebook.com slash awesome Walter
because someone took off some Walter
there's nine names on even Walter don't
know why I did that but good job you
guys
anyway check us out on there if you want
to talk to us a little bit more definite
leave your opinions about your favorite
top 5 episode below your best moments
what your favorite things are about to
show and look it's not gonna be a top 5
worst episodes of top 5 we here every
week what you guys don't like ok so we
appreciate you to input a negative
positive whatever thank you for reacting
to the show and sticking with us for so
long we will be back here next week with
a brand new episode of top 5 back to the
regular format but today today was a
good day to reflect 100 oh yeah years of
the show so thank you very much for
watching guys
I'm multiple easyacc I'm at the Reese
and we'll catch you next week on top 5
hi everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
you